as you've probably noticed the music
industry is a degenerate Wasteland full
of semi-literate drug addicts who spew
vulgarity and ugliness all over the
culture like a never-ending stream of
projectile vomit for just one example of
course one of the most talked about
songs of the summer called pound town
has the performer sexy red graphically
describing her various orifices in the
very first lines of the song and it's
all downhill from there this is what
passes for music in Modern Times And if
you criticize any of it if you object to
any of this filth no matter how
aggressively disgusting stupid and
morally deranged it is you are dismissed
as a prude if you do not want these
morons and perverts to dump this audible
sewage directly into your child's
eardrums then you're nothing more than a
fainting church lady clutching your
pearls the media will join in this
course of course insisting that the
music you object to is somehow actually
artistically brilliant sure the average
hit song these days sounds like it was
written in crayon on a piece of toilet
paper by an emotionally just served
adult who still wears velcro shoes but
you're supposed to love all of it and
never criticize any of it or else you
are nothing more than a puritanical
scold
but there are exceptions to this rule
every once in a while the very people
who love and defend the most heinous and
disgusting music imaginable will
encounter a song that they deem
offensive they go from calling everyone
else Pearl clutchers to clutching their
own pearls suddenly they're the ones
Fanning themselves and fainting these
are always interesting and informative
moments and we happen to be experiencing
one right now the song that has provoked
the Wrath of the sorts of people who
regularly celebrate the most demented
and hideous and artistically
irredeemable music ever made is from
country star Jason Aldean and it's
called try that in a small town this
song We Are informed is deeply offensive
I mean it's probably the most offensive
song that's been made this Century based
on the reaction so prepare yourself
here's a quick sample
somebody on a sidewalk
jacket
[Music]
around here we take care of our own new
cross
okay so just to review Aldine is
directing this at those who sucker punch
somebody on a sidewalk carjack an old
lady at a red light or pull a gun on the
owner of a liquor store and warning that
if they behave this way in a small town
uh they won't make it down the road
because as he says folks in small towns
take care of their own and don't put up
with that kind of nonsense
now someone who
lived in a town of fewer than three
thousand before moving to Nashville I
can confirm that this is basically how
it works in my experience in small towns
um I you know or whenever I lived I
never heard of anyone getting carjacked
or sucker punched on a sidewalk violent
crime was virtually non-existent and
this was all not in spite of but at
least partially because everybody
legally owned multiple firearms it was
certainly not uncommon to hear gunshots
coming from your neighbor's property not
because any crime was being committed
but because they were you know Outback
doing target practice or in the woods
hunting for deer these were not the
sorts of people you wanted to carjack or
randomly assault on the sidewalk which
is why that sort of thing rarely if ever
happened
that's what Jason Aldean was trying to
convey in his song
along with conveying that there's a you
know a sense of community that you can
find in a lot of these towns that
oftentimes you don't find in the bigger
cities which is also in my experience
true
but of course somehow this is all for
some reason offensive to many people on
the left
as mentioned there has been a deafening
Cry of outrage against this song many
tweets like this from a woman named
Reverend Dr Jackie Lewis who you know is
insufferable based on the fact that she
front loads her name with multiple
titles but she posted there's no
non-racialized way to write a song about
lynching when Jason Aldean sings sings
see how far you make it down the road it
invokes a very particular Legacy another
viral post agrees nobody could be
shocked by Jason Aldean writing a racist
as F song him and his skanky wife hang
out with Trump and dress their kids in
anti-biden clothing the song is as she
as he is
many more posts you know where these
came from all of a similar tone and
theme
The Daily Beast slam Dow Dean with this
headline Jason Aldean catches heat for
racist pro-gun lyrics a modern lynching
song
the outlet claims that the song is not
just a statement of Aldean's personal
politics but a disturbing Call to Arms
quote unquote they accused the singer of
quote suggesting that he's gearing up
for a race war
and by the way they're evidence for that
accusation that he mentions a race war
in the song is uh they they quote this
lyric from the song got a gun that my
granddad gave me they say one day
they're gonna round up
so The Daily Beast sees a race war in
that line somehow
I don't see it but I guess this is like
the leftist version of finding Jesus and
a piece of toast I don't know you know
as we get deeper into the summer uh it's
all the more important to think about
ways that you can maintain a healthy
lifestyle even if you're very busy and
one of the ways you can do that is by
eating lots of fruits and vegetables are
a great way to make sure that you're
getting essential nutritional
ingredients every single day through
balance of Nature's Advanced cold vacuum
process the vitamins minerals and
phytonutrients of the fruits and
vegetables are preserved so you can get
that vital nutrition in each capsule
balance of nature is a whole food
supplement with no additives no fillers
no extracts no synthetics no pesticides
or added sugar pure fruits and
vegetables are the only things they put
in their capsule it's as simple as that
balance of nature send a bunch of their
products down to the studio for my team
to try we all love them when you're
disciplined enough to take care of your
health you reap all the kinds of
benefits that are available to your your
body will thank you for it for a limited
time this summer when you become a
preferred customer a balance of nature
they're throwing in a free fruits and
vegetables travel set and giving an
additional 25 dollars off your first
order go to balanceofnature.com use
promo code Wells for a free travel set
and 25 off your first order as a
preferred customer it's
balanceofnature.com promo code Walsh as
you probably know if you watch the show
I'm constantly traveling uh being on the
road as much as I am I don't sleep well
at night I know it's because the hotel
sheets that I'm at or anywhere I'm
staying they're not as comfortable as my
cozy Earth sheets at home cozy Earth
sheets are the softest most luxurious
sheets that I have ever owned my wife
and I have their white bamboo sheets on
our bed these bamboo sheets are
temperature regulating helping us sleep
like sweet babies even on hot nights and
even when we have uh babies of our own
that are screaming and crying all night
maybe without that we would sleep well
cozy Earth offers an array of sizes and
colors to match your Unique Style and
preferences their sheets are made to
withstand the test of time myco's Earth
sheets get softer and softer with every
wash don't just take my word for it they
have over 5 000 happy customer reviews
on their site so what are you waiting
for cozy Earth offers a 100 night
guarantee so there's no harm in trying
it invest today in a good night's sleep
right now you'll save 40 off your next
purchase with promo code Walsh at
cozyearth.com that's promo code Walsh at
cozyearth.com
many other headlines echoed this
sentiment Perez Hilton published his own
screaming headline music fans Nationwide
condemned Jason Aldean's violent new
song and awful music video Big yikes
CNN agreed noting that the lyrics
allegedly evoke lynching and gun
violence
other artists have denounced Jason
Aldean last night Sheryl Crowe posted
this I'm from a small town even people
in small towns are sick of violence
there's nothing small town or American
about promoting violence you should know
that better than than anyone having
survived the mass shooting this is not
American or small town like it's just
lame
CMT the Country Music Television channel
joined the Dogpile by abruptly pulling
the music video from their rotation they
didn't give at this point an official
reason for that decision but the reason
is clear
the backlash eventually prompted a
lengthy response from Aldean who
released a statement yesterday with this
clarification quote try that in a small
town for me refers to the feeling of
community that I had growing up where we
took care of our neighbors regardless of
differences of background or belief
because they were our neighbors and that
was about that was above any differences
my political views have never been
something I've hidden from and I know
that a lot of us in this country in in
this country don't agree on how we get
back to a sense of normalcy where we go
at least a day without a headline that
keeps us up at night but the desire for
it that's what this song is about
now he also stipulates that this song is
not about race and does not promote
lynching
these stipulations are totally
unnecessary because everybody already
knows that the accusations are
completely absurd and meritless the
people making the accusations especially
know it
in fact if you immediately assume that
lyrics condemning carjackings and random
assaults are racist and anti-black
that you have revealed something about
your own feelings and assumptions about
black people okay if somebody says I I
hate to I hate carjackings and you say
well what do you got against black
people
you've admitted something about yourself
it's like if I said man you know I can't
stand the lazy smelly weirdos and you
said hey what's wrong with Mexicans
somebody in the exchange has made an
unflattering statement about Mexicans
and it wasn't me
something similar is going on with this
reaction to try that in a small town now
with all that said
I must admit that there are there are
some gratuitously violent lyrics in
Jason Aldean's song
okay we didn't play them before he was a
little bit offensive but uh I mean
listen to these lines from the song
I got some homies with pounds but we
ain't that cool so I'm thinking about
robbery gotta play this smart it's going
to hurt their heart when they find out
that it was me that was robbing them
gotta catch him when it's dark gonna run
up on his car that same one we always be
riding in ran up to his car made him
grab the wheel I grabbed his neck like
I'm Iron Man just do what I say no you
don't want to die in here if you reach
or you tweak I'm a fire in here
wow really violent stuff from Jason
Aldean
oh wait no that's not Jason Aldean I'm
sorry that's that's not Jason at all
that's one of the top rap songs on
YouTube right now from a rapper named
King Von
this is actually a posthumous song from
the artist who was a tragically killed
in a gang shooting a few years ago
before his death he had been implicated
in up to 10 different homicides okay
he's a rap artist with hit songs
including one right now after he died
implicated in 10 homicides
so he was potentially an actual serial
killer with a music video that has 10
times the number of views as Jason
Aldean's song right now
but Jason Aldean is the problem somehow
he's the one we're worried about
King Von is not a unique case the rap
genre is obviously full of actual
violent criminals who openly glorify
murder drug abuse rape robbery all
manner of violent crime they directly
call on their fans to engage in this
behavior and their fans respond
accordingly they have particular
influence over a fatherless inner city
kids who they coax down a road of
lawlessness and self-destruction this is
what you get in rap music which is why
every year or sometimes multiple times a
year rappers end up lying in the gutter
bleeding out as the lifestyle they
promote comes back to destroy them
Meanwhile we're still waiting as far as
I know for the first country artists to
be killed in a gang shooting it doesn't
happen because country artists aren't
the problem
the problem lies with the genres of
music that an automatic and Universal
pass from the very people pretending to
be scandalized by Jason Aldean
a few months ago billboard released its
list of the top rap songs of 2022 number
one on the list
is a glow glorilla and hit kid fnf part
of that is the song title part of it is
the name of the rapper I don't know
which is which but this song also made
the best songs overall of 2022 lists for
the Los Angeles Times NPR Pitchfork uh
Time Magazine
it's one of the hits of the previous
summer went massively viral on YouTube
and Tick Tock here's a brief sampling of
this artistic Masterpiece listen
ing
she said she can't come outside today
that means she's scared right I'll be
put up in the winter in the summer pop
out here at night
you better hold his head anyway life's
great
still eating cake
get my food upon a
on guns okay uh one of the best songs of
the entire year right there according to
NPR in the LA Times now you might argue
that the violent themes uh in that song
are less of a concern because the lyrics
are so illiterate stupid and
unintelligible it's hard to tell exactly
what she's even trying to say that's
perhaps the one benefit of having a
music scene overrun by mentally disabled
idiots with sub-75 IQs be that as it may
can anyone seriously argue that try that
in a small town is more objectionable
than the garbage you just heard
or any of the garbage just like it
of course the crucial difference between
try that in a small town and a song like
robberies or fnf whatever it's called
aside from the fact that Jason Aldean
can read above a third grade level is
that in the former case if the artist is
advocating for any form of violence he's
advocating for violence in self-defense
or in defense of the innocent against
predators
but in your typical rap song violence is
advocated against anybody and everybody
not for the sake of Defending yourself
or your community but for the sake of
profit or selling settling a score with
someone from a rival gang or proving how
tough you are Etc
you know if a rap song mentions
carjacking people at red lights or
pulling guns on liquor store owners
it'll be because the artist is bragging
about doing those things
Aldean condemns those crimes rap artists
explicitly promote and glorify them
a total indifference to human life
callous violent amorality that is what
you hear promoted in the kinds of songs
that will never ever under any
circumstance
be criticized by The Daily Beast or CNN
or Sheryl Crow or any of those people
so why does Al Dean get held to a
standard that is never applied to the
most popular rap artists in the world
well because Aldine is white number one
and conservative
and he sings country music I mean that's
the whole reason it's as simple as that
they accuse him of racism but it's their
own racism
they're anti-whitism
actually several forms of racism at play
here given all the assumptions that
they're making again about about black
people by taking his lyrics As racial
that's what's driving us
and their political bigotries as well
that's what's behind all of it
and we all know it
hey YouTube thanks for listening to the
show if you'd like access to my full
show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there